en
bonjour à tous vent de fronde au sénat
est la haute-assemblée détricote la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
elle a supprimé l es deux mesures phares
du projet de loi
la répartition des compétences entre les
collectivités et le mode de scrutin des
conseillers territoriaux
elle les centristes sont la clé de ce
scrutin ici au sénat où l'ump n'a pas la
majorité absolue et cette nuit ils ont
voté contre le mode de scrutin du
conseiller territorial entraînant ainsi
son rejet par le sénat le gouvernement
souhaitait un scrutin uninominal à deux
tours
mais les centristes exigé l'introduction
d'une dose de proportionnelle
autre article rejeté cette fois ci à la
quasi unanimité par le sénat
celui sur la répartition des compétences
entre les collectivités
le sénat a rejeté l'article visant à
supprimer la clause de compétence
générale pour les départements et les
régions
cette clause de compétence générale il
en sera encore question cet après-midi
lors de l'examen des articles réservés
il s'agit d'articles dont l'examen a été
repoussé à la fin de la discussion
afin de permettre au gouvernement de
trouver une majorité
et il sera bien sûr question de la
création du conseiller territorial
une création qui fait largement débat
ici au sénat tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle est très bonne
séance
il est en reprise alors toujours à
l'article le premier à a
je suis saisine quatre demandes de prise
de parole nous commençons par monsieur
michel teston et madame la présidente
c'est noté merci monsieur le président
je partirai d'un rappel les membres de
notre groupe sont opposés à la création
du conseiller territorial
si vous ne le saviez pas en effet la
mise en place d'élu siégeant à la fois
au conseil général et au conseil
régional laisse à penser qu'il s'agit
d'une première étape vers une fusion
entre ces deux collectivités
la création du conseiller territorial
opérerait une quasi fusion mais les deux
échelons de collectivités subsisterait
formant de pau deux personnes morales
distinctes avec des budgets et des
compétences distinctes ce projet de loi
ne respecte donc pas pleinement la
lettre de l'article 72 de la
constitution en effet où l'on fusionne
les deux échelons pour créer une
collectivité nouvelle géré par un
conseil territorial où l'on respecte la
séparation deux personnes morales
distinctes et partant l'existence de
deux assemblées d'élus en outre et je
n'ai déjà dit hier mais je le répète
encore aujourd'hui cette disposition
porte à mon avis atteinte aux principes
reconnus par la constitution d'absence
de tutelle d'une collectivité sur une
autre ce principe est ce qui est dans la
constitution est tellement ancrée dans
notre droit qu'en cas de coopération
entre collectivités
seule est autorisée l'existence d'un
chef de file ont la mission des
conseillers territoriaux pourraient leur
permettre d'orienter la prise de
décisions régionales en fonction
d'intérêts départementaux ou la prise de
décision départementale dans un sens
favorable à la région ainsi la tutelle
est inhérente au dispositif qui
découleraient de cette réforme
institutionnelle si par malheur elle
était adoptée en outre l'extrême
difficulté du gouvernement à proposer un
mode de scrutin adapté des manteaux s'il
est encore besoin que le problème réside
dans l'instauration elle même du
conseiller territorial
le gouvernement veut imposer la création
du conseiller territorial heures
qu'aucune association d'élus ne s'est
jamais prononcé dans ce sens
officiellement il s'agirait de réduire
le nombre d'élus afin de faire des
économies
discours important en période de crise
des dons ne sommes pas dupes
en réalité ce texte n'est pas sans
arrière-pensée
l'objectif n'est-il pas d'empêcher que
les assemblées des collectivités
départementales et régionales soient
majoritairement à gauche
la création du conseiller territorial ne
respecte pas un certain nombre de
principes essentiels la vie démocratique
la proximité la parité ou encore la
juste représentation des territoires
pourquoi supprimer le mode de scrutin
actuel des régionales qui donnent
satisfaction en assurant tout à la fois
une majorité la parité et la
représentation des minorités
d'ailleurs comment ne pas rappeler
qu'après avoir été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale est rejetée par la commission
des lois de notre assemblée
un tableau des effectifs des conseillers
territoriaux ray apparaît sous la forme
d'un amendement du rapporteur
ainsi à titre d'exemple de 18
conseillers territoriaux dans le texte
de l'assemblée nationale l'ardèche en
aurait désormais 19 soit en moyenne 25%
moins que des départements dont le
nombre d'habitants et pourtant
sensiblement inférieur je rappelle qu'il
y à 33 conseillers généraux et des
conseillers régionaux en ardèche
la réduction du nombre de ses élus
seraient ainsi de plus de 50%
où est la juste représentation des
citoyens et des territoires avec une
telle répartition les diverses
péripéties survenues lors des débats
témoigne de la difficulté du
gouvernement à structurer son projet il
est donc judicieux de ne pas modifier le
dispositif pour les régionales et de
maintenir les conseillers généraux qui
pourraient devenir des conseillers
départementaux élus dans des
circonscriptions plus équilibré que les
actuels canton cette analyse nous
conduit à réaffirmer avec force notre
opposition à la création du conseiller
territorial qui s'inscrit dans une
logique à peine dissimulée de remise en
cause de la décentralisation d'abandon
de la parité et de renoncement à une
juste représentation des territoires
la parole est à notre collègue monsieur
jacques blanc président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues et bien
moi je ferai un rappel je pars d'une
analyse inverse et je dois féliciter la
commission président rapporteur et les
auteurs de l'amendement qui ont permis
de mettre cet article a aujourd'hui dans
le texte
pourquoi je m'en réjouis parce que
justement il est capital qu on dise
qu'est ce que c'est que ce territoire
c'est pas une représentation du nombre
d'habitants c'est une représentation de
l'espace avec une homogénéité s'est dit
dans le texte
espace géographique économique et social
et ça nous permet de sortir des débats
légitimes entre représentations
territoire représentation de la
démographie et là nous affirmons mais ça
me paraît essentiel en particulier
vis-à-vis du conseil constitutionnel que
il s'agit bien d'un choix délibéré
un élu qui se raccrocher à ce territoire
on verra selon quelles modalités
mes chers collègues ne faisons pas de
psychodrame permanent
il est légitime qu'il ait débat sur des
modalités électorales c'est respecter
d'ailleurs les uns et les autres que
d'accepter ce débat mais par contre la
philosophie même qui ressort de cet
article c'est bien une représentation de
quelqu'un qui sera accrochée à un
terrain et qui sera à la fois membre du
conseil général et du conseil régional
là c'est pas écrit mais rapporteur nous
expliquera peut-être et mes chers
collègues
c'est une reconnaissance pour une
assemblée régionale de l'exigence
d'avoir un accrochage entre les élus le
terrain écoutez je connais un peu la
région j'ai présidé 18 ans lors la
région languedoc-roussillon
j'ai la faiblesse de dire qu'en dehors
du président
et de l'exécutif les conseillers
régionaux
personne ne les connaît pourquoi parce
que les listes qui sont fabriqués par
les partis politiques quels qu'ils
soient de droite comme de gauche ne crée
pas ce lien avec l'élu qui sera demain
le conseiller territorial et qui
apportera au niveau du conseil régional
à la fois cette connaissance intime de
proximité le fait ce soit les mêmes qui
seront conseil général et conseil
régional va faire tomber un certain
nombre de démarches divergentes
d'opposition ou autres et s'est agit pas
d'une fusion mais il s'agit pas non plus
ou pas
ce
un parent
et à ne pas les entendre alors l'article
1a consacre l'avènement du duo infernal
conseiller territorial et territoire
chargé donc d'incarner la fusion
d'absorption départements des régions
avec fatalement une des deux structures
qui sera amené à disparaître
et paradoxalement et là je suis en
désaccord entre le collègue jacques
blanc au même moment où par souci de
modernité artificiel je dirais on
élimine le canton de la carte pour des
raisons essentiellement démographiques
qui le disqualifierait au titre de
l'exode rural ont créé un territoire
censé effectivement mettre en adéquation
territoriaux graphique avec une
population et un bassin d'emploi tout en
conservant au niveau administratif
les cantons contraire comprenne qui
pourra
et d'ailleurs les normes difficultés
rencontrées pour essayer de définir le
conseiller territorial constitue
véritablement en elle-même une forme de
disqualification de ce nouvel élu avant
qu'il ait vu le jour en précisant
d'ailleurs de surcroît comme julien de
l'évoquer que personne au moment où nous
parlons n'est capable de définir quels
seront ses compétences
dès lors comment prétendre engagés à
travers ce texte une clarification des
compétences
alors que la plus grande confusion ça va
être dit par michel teston règne entre
les régions les départements qui ont des
compétences jusqu'à présent purement
distinctes vous entends dire également à
travers ce texte et réduire le nombre
des élus passent aussi les koning
d'économie et on me pardonnera à mon
tour d'évoquer le sujet du cas du
département de haute garonne que je
connais bien qui comptera maintenant 91
conseillers territoriaux qui siègeront
eux mêmes parmi les 255 que comprendra
la région midi pyrénées
voilà un chiffre la voie qui ne plaide
pas en faveur des intentions affichées
par roulement ainsi concerne les
économies à réaliser
en réalité et en conclusion à travers la
création du conseiller territorial
c'est véritablement une fracture des
territoires que vous prenez le risque
d'organiser en imposant de surcroît
confusion et austérité dans les
collectivités territoriales et on
comprendra facilement que la
détermination du groupe socialiste à
combattre ce projet sort renforcé du
fils et des bas madame la présidente
nicole borvo cohen seat
merci monsieur le président hier enfin
sur le président y est est sorti je
crois mais ces failles où il est mais je
ne voyais pas s'il voit pas bien si
lointain bien non parce que c'est celle
du bon il ya j'ai je me suis laissé
convaincre assez facilement sur le fait
que je ne pouvais pas des verts ne
pouvait pas défendre dans la suppression
du chapitre premier au motif que les
codes le conseiller territorial était
accepter en quelque sorte et à
l'assemblée et au sénat
bon je crois que j'ai eu tort
c'est pas très grave évidemment vous ne
l'auriez pas voté fin je suppose encore
qu'en sait plus très bien ce que vous
votez mais si je ne l'ait pas fait si je
me suis laissé convaincre
bon c'est parce qu'effectivement c'était
l'effet que je sais que les le sénat et
l'assemblée en gros ont accepté un
conseiller territorial mais vous
avouerez que ce que je voulais supprimer
le titre conseillers territoriaux qui
n'était qu'un mot dans un titre avaient
trait quand même à la réalité
d'aujourd'hui à savoir que sur cet objet
pas bien identifiés dès le départ on est
aujourd'hui de moins en moins identifié
puisque visiblement il n'y a pas
d'accord à l'heure actuelle sur le mode
de scrutin les circonscriptions et même
d'ailleurs on se demande sur quel type
de quel conseiller régional je dis bien
régional à dessein donc je crois
vraiment que on aurait pu quand même
accepté qu'on vote sur un titre qui est
pour l'instant qui plane un petit peu en
l'absence de contenu réel or je crois
que le libellé de cet article premier a
à nouveau et il était destiné surtout à
asseoir ce conseiller territorial qui de
fait n'existe pas encore de façon tout à
fait précise il était destiné à ça or
compte tenu de nos votes hier et compte
tenu de cette réalité que ce conseiller
territorial n'est pas bien assis je
trouve que le libellé de
cet article 1a a ne va pas du tout parce
qu'il veut asseoir le conseiller
territorial on l'a bien compris mais
vous pouvez la soir en disant qu' il ya
des conseillers territoriaux
une phrase disant qu'il ya des
conseillers territoriaux mais après il
est soit d'une précision mais soit d'une
imprécision total qui peut être
contredite ultérieurement par le mode de
scrutin les découpages électoraux qu'il
faudra bien fixer de façon précise et ça
c'est sur la forme si vous voulez donc
il ne correspond pas à grand chose
il peut être contredits et sur le fond
bien entendu nous ne sommes pas du tout
d'accord avec ce qui est inscrit mais ça
c'est autre chose nous voterons contre
et d'ailleurs nous avons un amendement
de suppression mais franchement
sur la forme le thé le département est
divisé en territoire ça alors ça me tout
dire et ça veut rien dire
bien le territoire d'une circonscription
électorale dans les communes constituent
un espace géographique économique et
social homogène
ça non plus ça veut pas dire grand chose
le découpage territorial du département
respecte sa diversité géographique
économique et social parce que ça
pourrait être le contraire on pourrait
découper le département autrement je
trouve ça quand même très curieux et le
conseiller territorial et le
représentant du territoire au sein du
conseil général
il est aussi dans votre conception
il est quand même l'élu régional donc
voyez je trouve que ce libellé destinée
à nous faire quand même passer à tout
prix
le conseiller territorial beaucoup plus
que le titre qui était pas suffisant
donc je n'aurais dû m'accrocher pour
qu'on vote sur le titre il est quand
même assez contre-productif je trouve
monsieur le président gérard longuet
oui mais c'est le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
prends la parole en partie pour répondre
à mon excellent collègue jacques blanc
mais surtout pas par plaisir et par
bonheur de défend le concept de
conseiller territorial qui est une
véritable innovation et qui permet qui
donne tout son sens à ce texte de loi
texte de loi connaît une progression
certes difficile je le reconnais mais ce
conseiller territorial est une véritable
valeur ajoutée pourquoi diable parce que
si la france et je me répète est une
république décentralisée elle n'est pas
fédéral il n'y a donc pas de pouvoirs
normatifs principal comme il y en a dans
les länder allemands ou dans les états
américains
au niveau des régions et des
départements la vocation de ces
collectivités
c'est d'apporter des services au
quotidien dans le cadre du département
ou dans le cadre de la région et pour
des compétences qui sont définies par la
loi
si nous avions des pouvoirs normatifs
principaux comme ont un pouvoir les
quasi législatif les lander allemands ou
les états américains il faudrait
essentiellement que les conseillers
territoriaux soit déconseillé
démographique
c'est à dire élus en fonction du nombre
parce que lorsque l'on construit une
norme qui s'applique à tous et qui est
générale au mieux que les élus soient
représentatifs de la population mais il
s'agit d'appliquer de faire en sorte par
exemple qu'un que les collèges
desservent la totalité d'un espace
départementale que le ramassage scolaire
des serbes
en effet les cantons en tenant compte
des inégalités territoriales
kilométrique de parcours d'enneigement
de difficultés il faut donc bien des
élus qui représentent des territoires
dont les problèmes sont en effet
spécifique
même si ces territoires non pas une
stricte égalité démographique
alors je me disent vous nous proposez un
compromis qui est acceptable - 20 % +20
%
c'est acceptable cela permet d'avoir une
certaine diversité à l'intérieur de
l'espace départemental
et puisque ces conseillers territoriaux
ont à la fois gérée par exemple
l'enseignement du premier cycle du
secondaire des collèges mais qu'ils
seront compétents pour le deuxième cycle
du secondaire c'est-à-dire les lycées
il n'est pas complètement anormal malgré
tout que leurs poids respectifs soient
comparables d'un département à l'autre
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
avez mis en place un système intelligent
dans lequel il ya une diversité des deux
territoires une diversité démographique
mais kylie a cher collègue jacques blanc
une comparaison qui fait qu en effet un
petit un grand département par l'image
département de lafayette mais un
département quand même plus petit par la
taille ne soit pas surreprésentés dans
une action dans une assemblée régionale
sinon les autres collègues régionaux du
rêve d'être bien gentil mais avec vos 70
mille habitants vous ne pouvez pas
cependant tout à fait faire la loi
donc nous avons bien ce conseiller
territorial qui dans les deux assemblées
c'est d'ailleurs la raison je me tourne
même les amis les collègues du groupe
centriste
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
défendu la clause de compétence réserve
général réservé aux communes et avec des
compétences spécialisées pour
départements et régions puisque
justement nous avons le même élu dans le
département et la région
et il y aura une organisation entre
départements et régions pour instituer
une la répartition optimum des
compétences entre départements et
régions en fonction de chaque
problématique régionale effort s'il
reconnaît que les problématiques
régionales ne sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes d'une région à l'autre de notre
pays et c'est justement pour cela que
j'avais défendez mais sans grand succès
je dois le reconnaître
l'idée qu'il fallait mettre en place
l'organisation de ses compétences aux
différents niveaux en les organisant et
en les structurant
quant à mon collègue challenge mais
pourquoi ne pas élire le président de la
région au suffrage universel parce que
vous rétablirez riez avec force le seul
poids de la démographie au détriment des
territoires et je le dis avec beaucoup
d'amitié pour justement ces vallées ses
plateaux de la lozère sans doute la
région languedoc roussillon n'aurait
jamais eu le bonheur d'avoir un élu de
cette terre de sagesse d'expérience de
solidité qu'est la lozère à la tête
d'une région où la démographie aurait
imposé ce qu'est le cas aujourd'hui
président de la zone la plus peuplée et
c'est bien en raison des territoires du
droit des populations être équitablement
servi dans la diversité de leurs
territoires qu'il faut défendre le
conseiller territorial et qu'il ne faut
pas suivre jacques blanc sur une
composition d'ailleurs qui n'a été
repris par personne
allez la parole est un autre collègue
il veut d'aubilly merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues élu d'un département
rural je veux être à nouveau ont
peut-être plus la dernière fois dans ce
débat le porte parole de nombre d'élus
lors je dirais pas de toute sensibilité
mais de diverses sensibilités pour dire
l'absurdité de ce conseiller territorial
dont on se demande s'il est le fruit du
rêve éveillé d'un président qui était en
panne d'imagination ou bien s'il est le
fruit du mauvais échos ce cauchemar d'un
technocrate à courre d'innovation lui
aussi ce conseiller territorial
cela a été dit devra gérer puisque pour
l'instant les compétences ne sont pas
changé il devra gérer les horaires des
transports scolaires la veille hivernale
des routes départementales
tout en étant une super assistante
sociale dans le même temps avoir donc
cette vision prospective sur l'évolution
stratégique sociologiques économiques de
la région devra à siéger dans un nid
nombre à bhl d'innombrables conseil
d'administration commission multiplier
les représentations
je veux dire qu'avec ce conseiller
territorial s'il existe parce que pour
l'instant il existe mais il n'y a
toujours pas de mode d'élection chacune
des deux chacun des deux niveaux de
collectivités territoriales perdra sa
spécificité et c'est bien l'indication
que la voie est ouverte à la fusion à la
suppression du département chaque niveau
perdra sa spécificité qui donnait à son
action publique à la fois sa force son
efficacité mais qui établissait aussi sa
reconnaissance
c'est à dire la proximité pour le
département l'impulsion et la
coordination pour la région
et dans ces vastes nouveaux cantons
ruraux qui seraient redécoupés le
département perdra ce qui était
l'essence même de son action publique
être proche du citoyen être proche des
élus être à l'écouté des habitants des
maires des conseillers municipaux
quant aux régions qui se rapprocheront
d'une certaine façon les anciens
établissements publics
elles retrouveront un système ancien
éloignés de leur vocation actuelle avec
le conseiller territorial cela a été dit
il faut le répéter vous n'apportez pas
de simplification vous n'apportez pas de
meilleure visibilité pour le citoyen par
contre vous allez détruire une
organisation territoriale certes
toujours perfectible qui a été
construite régulièrement patiemment sur
deux coupes de couple a trois
le premier c'est le bloc communal
communes et communautés de communes
départements qui est le blog de la
proximité et de la solidarité
le deuxième bloc s'est suivie de la
région de l'état et de l'union
européenne qui est le niveau de la
stratégie du développement de la
prospection pour quoi déstabiliser un
édifice construit progressivement qui a
fait la preuve je le disais de son
efficacité
derrière cette réduction annoncée dit du
nombre d'élus nous mesurons combien il y
a en fait la volonté de réduire l'action
publique de diminuer les services
publics et nous mesurons combien ces
objectifs s'il devait être à ta
porteront atteinte à la cohérence et à
la solidarité des territoires
je vous remercie allez monsieur
guillaume
merci monsieur le président excusez moi
pour ce contretemps et ce retard a lié
au transport en commun
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je ne pas
revenir sur l'installation du conseiller
territorial puisqu'il a été voté
conforme entre l'assemblée et le sénat
simplement pour dire ça nous semble
toujours être une hérésie semble
toujours plus tôt guette de l'innovation
être de la régression et ça nous semble
toujours être une recentralisation
je voudrais intervenir sur le territoire
dont il s'agit sur lequel doit
travailler le code travaillerai le
conseiller territorial
c'est cela l'arctique dont il dont il
dont il s'agit ce conseiller territorial
qui est d'un nouveau type par d'abord
d'un postulat qui moi me fait un peu
peur et qui s'apparente peut être un peu
au populisme montré du doigt les élus de
la république en disant qu'ils sont trop
nombreux
qu'il coûte trop d'argent et qu'il faut
diminuer par deux ce nombre d'élus c'est
à mon sens pas le bon angle pour aborder
cela ce n'est pas le bon angle et
peut-être qu'il faut qu plus fallu
parler d'efficacité et j'en viens
maintenant à l'efficacité les
territoires sur lequel serait élu ces
conseillers territoriaux indique la fin
de la ruralité et de la démographie de
la nuque de la démocratie dans la
ruralité pourquoi tout simplement parce
que lorsque un conseiller territorial
serait élue dans une circonscription de
20 25 mille habitants expliquez-moi
comment le lien essentiel sur lequel
vous avez voulu travailler hier toute la
soirée entre un homme ou une femme et un
territoire et des citoyens pour être
maintenu
c'est fini et lorsque ce même conseiller
territorial devra siéger dans les
conseils d'administration des collèges
dans les camps c'est d'administration
des lycées assister à toutes les
assemblées générales dans des régions
qui sont sensiblement grandet nous avons
la chance de vivre dans la même région
avec le le ministre mercier vous savez
très bien que du sud de man département
jusqu'au siège de la région il faut 2h30
de véhicules deux heures et demie de
voiture
c'est ça la réalité dans une dans une
région de 2,5 millions d'habitants
et bien tout simplement il n'est pas
possible de faire son travail le matin à
au département l'après midi à la région
sur des sujets qui seront totalement
différent sur des territoires qui
poseront problème
et avec des conflits d'intérêts n'en
doutons pas lorsque les conseillers
généraux seront à la région ils ont
tendance à défendre leur territoire
départemental
et ce qui pose un problème vraiment et
ce sur quoi nous nous battons est ce que
sur quoi nous contestons c'est tout
simplement l'architecturé administrative
que voulait que vous voulez mettre en
place ce n'est pas de l'innovation c'est
de la régression et on ne peut pas aller
de l'avant avec un conseiller
territorial qui ne pourra pas assumer
sereinement sans son travail en plus
puisque plusieurs collègues ont pris
l'exemple de nos de nos de nos régions
dans la région rhône-alpes dans laquelle
je vis il ya aujourd'hui 157 conseillers
régionaux
demain avec le tableau qui avait été
présenté il y en aurait 2 196 il faudra
donc construire un deuxième hémicycle et
je suis sûr que tout le monde sera
d'accord pour construire ce deuxième et
mystique ça donnera du travail aux
entreprises de travaux publics mais plus
plus sérieusement plus sérieusement il
est impossible aujourd'hui et tout le
monde si on regarde objectivement un peu
les choses
tout le monde est d'accord il est
impossible aujourd'hui de mettre en
place ce conseiller territorial
il ne pourra pas assumer ses fonctions
locales et les fonctions régionales en
même temps et nous pensons vraiment que
c'est un retour en arrière une sorte de
recentralisation
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
position de notre groupe est bien de
maintenir dès que ça aurait été de
maintenir les camps si régionaux de
maintenir des conseillers généraux en
rééquilibrant les cantons là nous sommes
d'accord on ne peut pas garder des
cantons qui vont de 1 à 40 peut-être
mais le fait d'avoir des cantons qui
ferait des territoires qui serait de 20
25 mille habitants signifie tout
simplement la mort des territoires
ruraux qui ne serait plus représenté par
un élu qui ne serait pas en phase avec
les territoires
je vous remercie très bien très bien
aller
monsieur jean pierre sueur jeu monsieur
le président je ne serai pas intervenue
si notre collègue gérard longuet n'avait
par une intervention tout à fait
brillante et intelligente santé tenter
de sauver le conseiller territorial et
je voudrais leur dire à monsieur gérard
longuet que pour ma part j'ai un grand
respect pour les militants et pour ceux
qui défendent les causes parce que nous
en sommes tous finalement et je trouvais
quand même courageux de sa part de
mettre son intelligence au bénéfice de
ce conseiller territorial un peu esseulé
qui n'a plus de mode d'élection donc on
ne sait même pas comment ils arrivent
qui n'a plus de compétences monsieur
blanc donc il est là il est là en
souffrance et j'apprécié que dans ce
contexte un peu difficile
monsieur gérard longuet s'employa à
soutenir ce conseiller territorial qui
tel un drapeau au milieu de la mer une
sorte de radeau qui est en train
d'essayer de survivre eux étaient là et
alors je trouvais que c'était quand même
quelque chose qui méritait d'être saluée
dont je salue mais en même temps je
trouve
non je trouve que monsieur gérard
longuet devrait se reporter à
l'excellent article
voyons que je ne suis pas négatif qu'il
a publiée dans le journal les échos où
il a vilipendé ce qu'il a appelé la
république des ronds points
il a dit il y en a assez de ces élus qui
arrive t'on des assemblées pour défendre
leurs ronds points
on peut dire défendre leur canton on
peut dire défendre leur territoire
on peut dire défendre les projets du
territoire dont ils sont les lui mais ce
qui ne va pas dans le système qui nous
est présenté et monsieur longuet a dit
mais si ce n'est pas comme en allemagne
les régions n'ont pas de pouvoirs
législatifs
oui mais il ya un défaut dans le
raisonnement que tout le monde va
comprendre mes chers collègues c'est que
je ne vois pas comment on peut inférer
du fait qu'il n'ya pas de pouvoirs
législatifs dans des régions françaises
le fait qu'il faudrait que l'élu du
département et de la région fut le même
la l'argumentation tombe comme parfois
les amendements comme les feuilles en
automne l'argumentation tome parce que
ça n'a strictement aucun rapport
est ce que je crains mes chers collègues
c'est que avec le conseiller territorial
qui est d'ailleurs morimont nous le
savons le localisme pourtant tout à fait
respectable car nous nous honorons de
défendre les collectivités territoriales
le localisme ne l'emportent au plan
régional comme l'on dit mes collègues
monsieur guillaume monsieur daudigny que
le localisme l'emportent au moment où
nous avons besoin dans le contexte
européen que nous connaissons d'avoir
des régions fortes plus grande avec
davantage de moyens et qui seraient
pourvus d'élus qui monsieur le président
aurait chevillée au coeur et au corps
tant qu'à faire
l'idée de défendre l'université la
science la recherche
vous voyez bien monsieur le président
dans votre région lab à défendre un
grand projet mérite méditerranée
avec une perspective européenne et
mondiale
rayonnante monsieur chaque blanc mais
vous n'allez pas nous dire qu'une
collection d'intérêt localistes produit
cette ambition forte et donc je salue je
salue mais vous n'êtes pas obligé par
les dames c'est blanc d'abord je
comprends ce jeu d'hervé pas nous avons
je ne vois pas ce que vous dites mais je
terminerais comme j'ai commencé par un
éloge à l'égard de monsieur gérard
longuet vous lui rapporterait je lui
dirai que les chants désespérés sont les
chants les plus beaux
et nous nous apprécions que monsieur
sueur n'est ni le souffle court ni la
démonstration rapide
allez monsieur jean pierre fourcade
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
après tout ce que je viens d'entendre
depuis le début de cette séance
je me permets avec beaucoup de prudence
beaucoup de modération beaucoup
d'humilité de rappeler que les trois
quarts de nos concitoyens vivent dans
les agglomérations urbaines et que dans
les agglomérations urbaines et notamment
celles qui sont importantes
ni le conseiller général ni le
conseiller régional ne sont connus et
que par conséquent au niveau de nos
concitoyens ils connaissent les maires
ils ne connaissent pas leur conseiller
général ils ne connaissent pas les
conseillers régionaux
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi la réforme
dont nous sommes en train de parler
aujourd'hui à la condition à la
condition messieurs les ministres que le
nombre de conseillers territoriaux soit
le plus restreint possible à la
condition qu'ils soient le plus
restreint possible deux trois ou quatre
maximum par circonscription électorale
car nos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale tiennent beaucoup à ce que les
conseillers territoriaux seraient élus à
l'intérieur des circonscriptions
législatives à venir à cette condition
le conseiller territorial deviendra un
personnage politique connu pour que les
habitants que les concitoyens pour ans
avec lequel ils pourront dialoguer et
par conséquent je crois que je crois mes
chers collègues que la création du
conseiller territorial
j'ajouterai monsieur le président à la
condition qu'ils souhaitaient lui avec
un système électoral simple que tout le
monde connaît et par un système
compliqué donnant beaucoup d'importance
aux partis politiques
eh bien je crois qu'à ce moment là nous
aurons créé au dessus des mers
et en dessous des députés un conseiller
territorial connue de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens qui pourrait arbitrer entre
les compétences exclusives de la région
et celle du département qui pourra
participer à des conventions de gestion
commune pour un certain nombre de
services publics qui sont importants moi
je crois que le conseiller territorial
de ce point de vue là est une réforme
très importante et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je le voterai aucun des
amendements de suppression qui nous sont
proposés la parole est à notre collègue
monsieur jean louis masson
pour ma part je les ja d'hier je suis
partisan de la réforme de la création
des conseillers territoriaux
ceci étant je dois faire tout d'abord
une remarque suite a indiqué notre
collègue fourcade en disant qu'il faut
créer les territoires à l'intérieur des
circonscription de député
bon moi je suis radicalement contre
parce que dans certains départements on
a vécu des charcutage éhontée au moment
du redécoupage des circonscriptions
législatives
on a vu des choses absolument honteuse
notamment dans le département de la
moselle
on va quand même pas revenir maintenant
refaire du rotin sur le honteux parce
que si on pérennise le honteux on se
demande où on va s'arrêter alors ça
c'est ma première remarque est la
deuxième remarque c'est que cet article
que nous avons là tout en étant
favorable aux conseillers territoriaux
je ne vois pas très bien à quoi il sert
parce qu'il s'est quand même plus
pertinent de voter d'abord le mode de
scrutin et ensuite éventuellement
d'évoquer cet article
cet article tel qu'il est là tout seul
isolé dans le désert il sert strictement
à rien et c'est pourquoi tout en étant
pour la réforme des conseillers
territoriaux
je voterai con pour la suppression de
cet article monsieur jean rené lecerf
même se passer dans chaque collègue
quelques petites remarques
d'abord pour dire que je suis étonné
pour ne pas dire consterné d'entendre
effectivement des collègues qui sont en
même temps sénateur président du conseil
général pour certains d'entre eux maires
de communes de moins de 3500 habitants
peut-être même peut-être même présidents
d'intercommunalités
et qui paraissent assez satisfait de
l'action qu'il mène jugé totalement
leurs collègues conseillers généraux ou
conseillers régionaux incapables
d'assumer ses deux responsabilités
quelle belle opinion vous avez de vous
mes chers collègues et quelle piètre
opinion vous avez de vos collègues
conseillers généraux conseillers
régionaux
deuxième point la ruralité est
extrêmement intéressant de s'intéresser
à la ruralité vous auriez peut-être pu
réfléchir à tout petit peu au point de
savoir comment et est aujourd'hui
représenté la ruralité au niveau des
régions et comment les partis politiques
respectifs prévoit effectivement cette
ruralité au niveau des régions dans le
texte tel que nous nous allons le voter
et qui finira bien par être voté
vous aurez effectivement par le biais
des conseillers territoriaux
une représentation de la ruralité dans
les régions sans commune mesure avec ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et enfin j'écoutais moi qui suis
conseiller général depuis 22 ans d'un
couteau de plus de 50000 habitants où
j'ai six collèges 3 publiques trois
privées où je ne me suis pas sentie
jusqu'auprès jusqu'à présent incapable
d'assumer de manière parallèle et les
fonctions de conseiller général et de
maire d'une ville de 40 mille habitants
pendant des années et ensuite les
fonctions de conseiller général et les
fonctions de sénateur
j'écoutais avec beaucoup d'intérêt
l'intervention de monsieur le président
du conseil général de l'aisne et j'avais
quelques hôtes en ce qui me concerne
mais puisque jamais je ne me suis
promené sur les routes départementales
avec ma brouette et montceau de goudron
pour me préoccuper effectivement des
problèmes à la suite du gel hivernal
mais je me dis finalement que le rôle du
conseiller général c'est peut-être plus
un rôle de conception un rôle de
perspectives un rôle de prospective et
que cela ça me paraissait éminemment
comparables est éminemment possible de
le concilier au niveau départemental et
au niveau régional alors si on devenait
un petit peu sérieux ça me paraîtrait
une bonne chose
allez la parole et à notre collègue
monsieur françois fortassin
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
moi j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises et je
le répète les raisons pour lesquelles je
considérais que le système aurait des
difficultés à fonctionner et je vais
sortir des terres du languedoc
roussillon tout simplement parce que il
ya une tradition dans ces termes pour
aller vers midi pyrénées dans les terres
du languedoc roussillon aux marches
facilement sur les cadres politiques ses
adversaires mais fort heureusement tout
le monde est encore vivant étant donné
que la politique chacun le sait seule la
mort physique et irrémédiable pour me le
prends tout à fait pour dire qu'il y a
quelque chose de fondamental sur les
élus les collectivités locales
ils doivent pouvoir conserver
s'ils le souhaitent leur activité
professionnelle
je vois mal de mains des élus de
l'aveyron des hautes pyrénées pour
prendre dans la région midi pyrénées qui
pourront en même temps s'occuper des
affaires du département des affaires de
la région et en même temps avoir une
profession
ça c'est le vrai me semble t'il vrai
problème pour le reste je dirais que
comme nous avons été un certain nombre à
être à la fois conseillers généraux et
conseillers régionaux mais c'est un
choix que nous avions fait c'est
possible sauve à défendre d'une manière
tout à fait ardente et je ne suis pas de
ceux là
le mandat unique l'autre écueil que je
vois et nous allons toujours prendre
dans la région midi-pyrénées 250 ou 260
élus je plains un tout petit peu le
futur président
de la région midi pyrénées qui va avoir
face à lui
huit présidents de conseils généraux qui
vont arriver avec leurs bataillons le
président de la métropole toulousaine
qui fera de même
je ne sais pas effectivement la
politique cohérente qui pourra mener
échapper à la territorialisation ensuite
une assemblée de 200 et quelques membres
ça va très bien lorsqu on légifère un
peut-être un tout petit peu moins bien
lorsqu'il faut traiter des dossiers
techniques ce qui revient à dire en fait
qu' il y aura des sortes de grandes
messes deux ou trois fois par an et que
c'est la commission permanente qui
réglera l'essentiel des problèmes alors
cela je crois il faut le signaler
pour le reste je dirais que le
conseiller territorial existe mais tant
qu'on ne sait par quel est son
territoire ou comment il sera élu il est
évident que ça reste encore un
personnage relativement virtuel voilà ce
que je souhaitais exprimer
étant entendu qu'il faut quand même que
nous ayons toujours la sérénité et si on
peut s'y ajoute un brin d'humour c'est
pas plus mal en politique bien allez
monsieur jean claude peyronnet y encore
quatre orateurs inscrits au primaire
après peut-être noté monsieur patriat
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on s'arrête à
vous peser un peu plus d'une heure que
nous sommes sur ce temps de parole c'est
le président je n'avais pas du tout
l'intention d'intervenir c'est
l'intervention de monsieur monsieur le
serbe qui me pousse à le faire il est
vrai que l'intervention de monsieur
fortassin va me permettre d'avoir une
intervention très courte
oui je crois que monsieur le cers est
intervenu de façon brillante vraiment
mais avec une certaine mauvaise foi
parce que c'est vrai que nous sommes que
nous voulions non des professionnels de
la politique
en ce sens que nous n'avons que cette
activité pour la plupart d'entre nous et
oui mais oui normalement il devrait pas
bref donc sur le serbe
il est clair que c'est ça la question et
c'est que en effet comme le disait
monsieur fortassin il va être absolument
impossible d'avoir un métier dans les
fonctions nouvelles de conseiller
territorial
sauf avec les conséquences que cela
entraîne c'est à dire qu' il faudra que
ce soit des professionnels mais que donc
ils soient financés à la hauteur
convenable pour exercer ce métier là que
ce mandat là qui devient métier il
faudra une retraite il faudra la
sécurité sociale de façon satisfaisante
une complémentaire et c est donc tout ça
c'est indispensable
il faudra prévoir le retour à l'emploi
autrement dit il faudra prévoir le
statut de l'élu alors c'est une bonne
chose de ce côté là mais vous allez être
très vite confronté à ce problème là si
vous voulez que il y une certaine
difficile diversité professionnelle
j'ajoute que où sont les économies dans
cette perspective là ça n'a pas du tout
été chiffrée et et je pense que au bout
du compte par ce biais là en particulier
il y aura au contraire un surcoût et un
surcoût important
la parole est à notre collègue alors à
monsieur assouline
un bien j'ai des choses particulières
notamment avec l'intervention de
monsieur le 5 mai sur cette question des
territoires
quand on voit la difficulté pour nos
concitoyens à identifier la pertinence
des circonscriptions parfois même des
cantons on doit s'interroger sur les
efforts et les situations très
particulières qui ont permis à des
moments de pouvoir créer des territoires
qui correspondent à quelque chose pour
la nation il ya eu un effort gigantesque
mené de façon drastique et en un court
laps de temps et c'est le seul moment
vie dessus encore ça a été après la
révolution française
pourquoi parce qu'il y avait une vision
un projet est une nécessité sociale
économique de développement de cohérence
politique d'unité de la nation qui
donnait ce souffle aujourd'hui comment
vit-on nous faire croire que pour les
français
créer ce qu'on va appeler le territoire
vingt et un ans dit et un identifiant
quelconque parce que ouais le projet où
est le souffle où est le dynamisme ou et
l'ambition reprendre à la gauche
les collectivités locales eh ben c'est
un peu minable et danser un peu minable
quand on a si peu d'ambition quand c'est
à ce point politiciens alors à ce moment
là à ce moment là on fait n'importe quoi
la deuxième question que je voulais
soulever c'est monsieur le serbe qui
soulève un problème mais il faut aller
au bout
oui nous sommes ici des privilégiés nous
pouvons arrêter pour ceux qui veulent se
consacrer vraiment à la tâche
une activité professionnelle ya pour
certains un petit risque mais quand même
une certaine sécurité
pour le col pour le conseiller
territorial
pour aujourd'hui la majorité de nos élus
locaux
cette quelque chose inenvisageable sans
non seulement les couper de ce qui fait
il compris leur réalité quotidienne mais
de ne serait-ce pouvoir pour eux
envisager un petit peu une sécurité pour
les années qui suivent donc vous les
mettez dans cette situation mais je
prends ou des films sur le circuit et
pau qui a voulu évoquer ceux qui sont
présidents de cg machin est tout je vous
annonce vous le savez probablement si
vous lisez la presse que nous allons
déposer et à l'assemblée et au sénat un
projet de loi qui s'attaquera au cumul
des mandats mais proposera un statut de
l'élu
mais proposera un statut de l'élu pour
sécuriser l'ensemble des élus de notre
territoire pour que ce soit quelque
chose de reconnu de sable et de juste
pour tout le monde
je veux finir par une remarque bien un
lien quand même avec ce que nous faisons
ici je regarde tout à l'heure le fils de
la sp et je vois pas ce que ça mais
assez pensé quand j'ai vu monsieur
fourcade parlé et je vois une dépêche
qui dit que pour la société du grand
paris est bien le décret qui vient de
tomber dit qu'il y aura une dérogation
qui permettra à un élu de plus de 70 ans
dette le président je me suis dit bon
j'étais ici dans cet hémicycle a parlé
du grand paris on en a discuté
longuement on a eu les arguments
contradictoires puis c'était dans la loi
proposé ça c'est pas un décret on a fait
sauter cet article parce qu'on a jugé
collectivement que c'était pas bien on a
été en cnp l'assemblée l'a même pas
rétabli
donc là le parlement dans son ensemble a
dit c'est pas bien et il ya un décret du
gouvernement qui dit eh bien ça sera le
cas
pas parce que ça tombe du ciel il vient
parce qu'on en a discuté ici donc il
vient dire
je m'en fous du parlement et moi je vous
dis dans nos débats
même quand on discute ici quand on
découvre qu'on peut s'en à ce
point de choses qui sortent y compris
par consensus de nos assemblées
eh bien il faut le souligner ici et le
dénoncer
c'est proprement inadmissible parce que
c'est fait que pour une seule raison
parce qu'on a en tête qu'on doit mettre
une personnalité à la tête de cet
organisme et qu'elle a plus de 70 ans et
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec l'intérêt
général ça renvoie à plein de choses en
ce moment oui merci aussi allez monsieur
patriat ce mettant attendait ce sujet un
calmant nous
allez monsieur patriat vous avez la
parole et vous seuls
ce président mais chers collègues nous
voyons bien depuis plus d'une semaine
que nous travaillons sur ce texte qu'ils
n'ont pas pour but de cul réformer les
collectivités n'ont pas pour but de
simplifier n'ont pas pour but
d'économiser
mais pour seul et unique but de créer
enfin ce conseiller territorial dont le
mode d'élection putatif permettra
effectivement qu'on vient de dire david
de reconquérir des territoires perdus
dans les yeux c'est ça alors j'ai
entendu monsieur diop son argumentation
monsieur le cers et bien sûr qu'on peut
être conseiller général et régional
vous avez raison vous avez raison je
l'étais je l'étais à une époque où et où
existait le p r mais je me souviens du
mode de fonctionnement et c'est parce
que je m'en souviens que je ne souhaite
pas revenir à cette méthode
hantée strahl strahl et à ce mode de
fonctionnement inique
parce qu'en fin de compte c'est par le
conseiller territorial en soi qui est
contestable c'est l' architecture qui
est autour qui empêchera qu'elle
fonctionne bien
pourquoi parce que les conflits
d'intérêts entre les collectivités de
par leurs étiquettes différentes
empêchera demain au président du conseil
régional d'avoir toute autorité et par
là même toute efficacité sur les
missions qui sont les siennes celles qui
sont celles de la perspective de
l'orientation de la formation de
l'innovation de l'enseignement supérieur
écoute
ce que dit notre collègue adnot écouter
ce qu'il dit comment comment demain un
président de conseil régional nom ne
vous est pas trompé s'agit pas d'amour
essayer non mais c'est d'accord alors
essaie de me comprenait un président de
conseil régional qui aura dans son
conseil régional quatre six ou sept
présidents de conseils généraux dont les
intérêts ne seront pas identiques dans
l'étiquette politique sera différente et
qui viendront faire leurs courses à la
région comment pourront-ils être
efficace demain c'est ça que nous
contestons c'est pas le conseiller
territorial en soit c'est le fait que ce
conseiller territorial va créer la
négation même du fonctionnement des deux
assemblées
parce que la logique de votre mais vous
ne l'avez pas fait et monsieur le
ministre l'a dit n'a pas fait la logique
du conseiller territorial c'est le
territoire unique c'est la suppression
d'un échelon
vous ne voulez pas vous le faire vous ne
pouvez pas le faire et comme vous ne
pouvez pas le faire
vous essayez par la bande de façon un
peu cynique de reconquérir les
territoires à travers ce qui serait
l'objet magique
le conseiller territorial bien sûr que
peut être conseiller général maire
préconise comme bien sûr y compris
doivent avoir un métier à côté
ils ont été exercés c'est pas ça le
problème le problème c'est que ça ne
pourra pas fonctionner ça ne
fonctionnera pas ou alors le conseil
régional deviendra des conseils généraux
bis à hulu le rond-point l'emportera sur
l'innovation ou bien à versements les
départements se fonderont de demain et
la proximité ne sera plus assurée c'est
ça qui aujourd'hui j'utilise notre
démarche et c'est pour ça ça ne peut pas
fonctionner
allez monsieur monsieur collombat je
voudrais à dire oui qu'on ne parle
jamais aussi bien que de ce qui est
virtuel que je voudrais attirer
l'attention des collègues sur sur trois
points le premier secteur calculé comme
comme vous voulez vous ne pouvez pas ne
pas faire que vous allez faire
disparaître massivement des élus de
proximité là où ils sont le plus
nécessaires dans les territoires ruraux
pour les augmenter
là où ils le sont un peu moins dans les
territoires urbains
si je prends par exemple ce qui va se
passer dans ma région
eh bien je constate que les deux
départements alpins qui sont quand même
beaucoup de territoires vont perdre la
moitié de la conseillers généraux c'est
à dire c'est à dire 30 que pour le
département du style alpes-maritimes var
vaucluse
enfin et c'est certes un gain d'autres
perth a fait match nul et que les
bouches du rhône vont en gagner 18
bon ça fait je termine seul e vous
pouvez pas ne pas faire que vous et à
condition encore que le conseil
constitutionnel avalisera ce qui est
certainement pas encore oui si sur ces
cas très particuliers ce qui est encore
pas gagné
bon je compte sur vous mais c'est pas
gagné bon donc ça vous calculez comme
vous voulez deuxièmement si maintenant
alors pour répondre à l'argumentation de
monsieur marc l'ex quand on fait le
total des dépenses
rires des budgets des départements
compte administratif 2008 63 milliard
des régions 63 milliards six cent des
régions 24 milliard
donc vous calculez comme vous voulez les
départements gèrent des budgets qui sont
à peu près deux fois et demie supérieurs
à ceux de la totalité des régions
donc ils seront peut-être
plus présent nos conseillers
territoriaux ruraux à la région mais là
où véritablement il y a de l'argent et
où il y a il y a de quoi gérer la
proximité c'est plutôt dans les
départements et pour finir
pour revenir à ce que se dit d'autres
collègues tout à l'heure le conseiller
territorial
le conseiller territorial sera-t-il plus
visible en zone urbaine que ne l'était
le conseiller général et le conseiller
régional réunis c'est pas sûr du tout et
encore moins encore moins sur un terreau
et stella encore pour rapid eye et et
dans les métropoles dans les métropoles
ils n'auront pas la compétence pour les
compétences transférées
ça sera les conseillers métropolitain
alors écoutez soyons un peu un petit peu
réaliste
donc je crois que quand même il ya
quelques bons arguments pour que on nous
prive de cette innovation qui est le
conseiller territorial
et puis j'en resterai là car les grandes
douleurs sont muettes très bien et bien
dans ce cas là si nous en restons là
nous allons prendre les amendements sur
l'article 1er aa et nous commençons par
un amendement ou 85 madame mathon poinat
oui merci monsieur le président je pense
que et la suppression de ces événements
je serais assez brève compte tenu des
des choses dites est souvent fort
pertinente cette suppression de cet
article qui d'ailleurs est issu de l'un
des membres de la commission des lois de
monsieur portelli sur la forme et sur la
forme nous nous nous le dénonçons sur la
forme d'ailleurs parce qu'il parte il
il anticipe sur le devenir de la réforme
territoriale
le conseiller territorial sera-t-il
finalement adopté ce concept comme
disait monsieur longuet est ce que ce
concept prendra cher
on peut se dire que peut-être et nous
coûtera cher si c'est le cas mais en
tous les cas il est fort possible que ce
texte finissent finissent très mal et
puis votre je pense que il anticipe
également sur le sur le futur projet de
découpage électoral alors c'est vrai que
je vois bien votre douce illusion
d'ailleurs de détruire les
contre-pouvoirs que sont les
collectivités locales et d'essayer de
reprendre en main sans doute de grandes
les régions que pourrais-je vous dire de
plus si ce n'est que l'examen de ce
texte mais si je poursuis quand même que
c'est l'examen de ce texte nous a quand
même offert de nombreuses surprises et
que cet article 1 s'inscrit quand même
dans cette confusion et risque de
perturber gravement la démocratie locale
crée donc une nouvelle circonscription
territoriale comme tel que le propose
monsieur portelli épaissir à la fois le
millefeuille puisque de toute façon le
canton demeure et en même temps et
demeure sur le point à une point de vue
administratif mais dans la volonté est
quand même sous jacente est bien là
à terme en tous les cas la suppression
du département
donc c'est un vrai du nom du département
et donc c'est un vrai recul démocratique
qui constituera l'instauration de ce
conseiller et c'est sa création est
votée 268 de monsieur desessard oui
monsieur le président mais je vais être
reçus prison parce que j'ai l'impression
je voudrais je crois monsieur ce cet
amendement soit supprimée cet article
après la première lecture au sénat
nous avons entendu le gouvernement
parlait d'un texte prometteur où en
sommes nous aujourd'hui
après l'émiettement d'un texte mal
élaboré sans dessein clairement annoncé
sans parité 100 simplifications
administratives sans transparence ni
démocratie face à un élu jomby qui nexis
qui n'existe que par son nom car pour
introniser ce dernier que de coups
d'essais et d'erreurs
tout d'abord le gouvernement nous parle
d'un scrutin uninominal à un tour
fallait oser puis il promène dose de
proportionnelle
puis ultime ultime suspense ya vote
et puis maintenant le débat différé
aujourd'hui pour introniser ce dernier
il n'y a plus rien plus de modalités
pour de désignation du conseiller
territorial
alors cet amendement en tire les
conséquences il supprime l'article
premier à et la notion de territoire qui
le sous-tend messieurs les ministres
ce spectacle d'équilibriste n'intéresse
pas la population dont le quotidien
s'aggrave et à qui vous promettez la
rigueur inégalitaire ces débats brouille
le peu de lisibilité qu'avaient les
lecteurs espèce en voie de disparition
si nous continuons à perdre du temps
avec des réformes non souhaitée et
lisible alors aujourd'hui l'idéal serait
que le gouvernement cesse de s'obstiner
et renonce au conseiller territorial
tel que prévu c'était lui sera surchargé
et sur notabilisé à l'opposé des
attentes de la population qui voudrait
des élus disponibles mode s et d'accès
facile pour parler des vrais problèmes
alors c'est pour ça que nous proposons
de supprimer cet article est le nom du
conseiller territorial à l'est de la mer
2481 rectifier de monsieur le président
il colle un oui monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
effectivement nous demandons par cet
amendement
la suppression de l'article premier
acquis substitut l'appellation de
territoire à celle de canton il s'agit
d'abord de défendre une position de
cohérence avec l'amendement que nous
avons défendu avant l'article 1er à agde
et qui proposait de faire des
intercommunalités la brique du découpage
cantonal
il s'agit ensuite pour nous ne nous
opposer une nouvelle fois sommes têtus à
la création du conseiller territorial
cet article par acte de ce nouvel élu
dont nous contestons toujours la
pertinence de plus les éléments
développés par cet article respect de la
diversité géographique économique et
social du département nous paraissent
entrer en contradiction totale avec ce
que sous-tend la présente réforme
comment parler en effet d' équilibre de
la représentation et de la prise en
compte des bassins de vie dans des
départements ruraux alors que la
création de seulement 15 sièges dans
nombre d'entre eux entraînera une
sous-représentation patente de la
population seulement dictée par des
impératifs comptables
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que nous
demandons de supprimer cet article me
demandant de se rallier à cet amendement
je vous remets bien
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur peut-on connaître l'avis de
la commission sur ces trois amendements
oui monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres
en fait il faut revenir à à l'origine de
cette opération
c'est en deuxième lecture lorsque nous
sommes arrivés en commission des lois
que notre collègue hugues portelli a eu
l'excellente idée de déposer un
amendement pour définir ce que serait
effectivement la circonscription du
conseiller territorial et il a défini
cette circonscription en disant que le
territoire est une circonscription
électorale ce qui sera intéressant
d'ailleurs dans la suite du débat parce
que vous verrez comme savez chers
collègues que la notion de canton reste
et demeure quelque chose une notion qui
est très ancré dans la population
d'autant qu'ils aient les fonctions
administratives qui vont avec le canton
notamment le chef lieu de canton
et puis peut y avoir la gendarmerie la
poste la perception et notamment les
chefs de canton je vous rappelle que
notion de chocs frontaux quelque chose
d'important
donc notre volonté c'est de dire déjà le
canton en tant que circonscription
administrative restera et le territoire
c'est une circonscription donc
électorale dont les communes et je crois
que c'est extrêmement important pour
nous qui voulons défendre les communes
dont les communes constituent un espace
géographique économique et social
homogène
à partir de ce moment là la commission
des lois a accepté a adopté l'amendement
de notre collègue hugues portelli et on
a fait le sien dans cette même logique
la commission des lois ne peut donc
mettre un avis défavorable aux trois
amendements qui veulent supprimer cet
article 1a à qui je le répète ce sera
extrêmement important parce qu'il permet
aussi s qui sera là aussi comme une
valeur intéressante nous parlerons du
tableau il permet de définir que le
tableau qui donnera le nombre de
conseillers territoriaux n'est pas
qu'une donnée essentiellement
démographiques et ceux qui sont attachés
effectivement avoir un coefficient
correctif pour tenir compte du
territoire devrait au contraire être
particulièrement content et satisfait de
voir cette définition parce que devant
le côté émotionnel si effectivement la
loi y est transcrite ce sera la
justification de dire que pour nous
le découpage territorial de tenir compte
des communes d'un espace géographique et
d'un espace des mots clés des mots
graphique
donc c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important et je vous invite mes chers
collègues a rejeté ces trois amendements
c'est pour ça que la commission l'avis
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre sur
les trois ou six
oui merci monsieur le président je
voudrais quand même dire que on est dans
une situation qui me paraît un peu un
peu paradoxal on vient on vient de
passer une heure et demie une heure et
demie à discuter des amendements sur un
texte qui a été introduit par votre
propre commission des lois et c'était
une initiative émanant du sénateur
hugues portelli et très très bonne
initiative très bonne proposition
donc moi juge trouve 16 un peu paradoxal
quand même un bon alors c'est un
enrichissement des textes du
gouvernement par le sénat est un
enrichissement important en effet
l'article qui les proposait de supprimer
est motivée par la nécessité de
conserver
globalement les cantons actuels issus
des deux lois très ancienne de 1789 et
qui sont restés pour l'essentiel depuis
cette date la circonscription de base de
nos départements donc à la fois
circonscription administrative de l'état
siège de la gendarmerie dans la plupart
des cas de la perception dans de très
nombreux cas encore de collège et
circonscriptions électorales puisque
c'est le lieu d'élection du conseiller
général
donc ce canton ne doit pas perdre
évidemment cette fonction administrative
et cette dimension administrative à
laquelle nous tenons tous moi aussi je
suis conseiller général et je tiens à ce
que cette notion soit toujours prises en
compte
et deuxièmement cet amendement la
création vise par la création de ce
nouvel article 1er aa
la création par ce nouvel article sa
conception électorale propre département
servant d'élection aux conseillers
territoriaux donc permet de ne pas faire
disparaître ni les actuels quand on
entend que circonscription
administrative ni la qualité de leur
chef lieu aux communes qui les possèdent
aujourd'hui et c'est quand même un
avantage important pour ces communes
chef lieu de canton auquel nous sommes
également attachés donc le gouvernement
le gouvernement ne peut que s'opposer à
cette suppression qui priverait d'un
ajout très utile le projet de loi de
réforme des collectivités territoriales
et il serait paradoxal que ce soit le
sénat qu'il supprime bien mes chers
collègues explication devant toulouse ou
nice
non ce président je demandais une
information puisque nous avions quatre
amendements en discussion commune et dès
le troisième sans information
supplémentaire à savoir s'il y avait eu
un quelconque retrait du 547 vous avez
donné la parole aux présidents de
rapporteur et au gouvernement
je voulais m'enquérir de savoir ce qu'il
était advenu du 547 monsieur hollis
l'amendement que vous évoquez a été
retiré avant le début de la séance et
par conséquent pour laquelle je ne vais
pas donc le conducteur a été remis
haas avait un petit décalage dans
l'information d'accord très bien je vous
en remercie alors je suis saisi
monsieur méar si monsieur le président
messieurs les les ministres simplement
par rapport à à cet article je croyais
que nous étions dans une loi de
simplification
or l'article 1a à nous informe qu'il va
exister des territoires et que en même
temps les cantons vont subsister comme
circonscription administrative alors
très ce côté monsieur sido laissez-moi
aller jusqu'au bout nous pouvons avoir
là dessus
une explication pour confirmer notre
demande de suppression constate
aujourd'hui que dans une loi de
simplification pour nos concitoyens qui
sont sur le terrain et sur le ministre
par l'ex rappelé à juste titre qu'il est
conseiller général est bien dans sa
circonscription de conseiller général
qui vraisemblablement dont les limites
électorale évolueront je suppose
peut-être peut-être
et bien non ses concitoyens se
retrouveront avec un territoire
électoral est un canton administratif
qui subsistera nous considérons que
c'est vraiment la démonstration de la
complexification du système toujours is
vegas toujours explications de vote de
monsieur dos mais elle tue le président
messieurs les ministres
nous examinons le premier article d'un
chapitre qui a pour nom les conseillers
territoriaux alors vous
on peut parler des conseillers
territoriaux alors qu' on ne sait pas
combien ils seront on ne sait pas
quelles seront leurs compétences on ne
sait pas comment ils sont il n'existe
pas et voilà et voilà que dès le premier
article
on veut attribuer à ses conseillers
territoriaux qui n'existe pas un
territoire
alors vrai que c'est un peu surréaliste
mais je profite donc je voterai bien sûr
ces amendements de suppression
mais je voudrais revenir sur la les
arguments qui ont été avancés tout à
l'heure c'est vrai c'est vrai que healy
a aujourd'hui des élus qui sont à la
fois conseiller général et conseiller
régional c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il
cumule c'est vrai que certains cumulent
des fonctions
ils ont choisi ils l'ont choisi
et il n'ya pas confusion il n'ya pas
confusion comme ce sera le cas comme ce
serait le cas pour les conseillers
territoriaux
car les consignes et territoriaux tous
les conseillers territoriaux seraient
tous cumulera les deux fonctions
et avec tous les dangers que cela peut
présenter et je vais si vous permettez à
ce que je peux continuer ça monsieur le
président sans être interrompu monsieur
comme zelda gong nous avons lu et
parcelles monsieur vasselle lorsque vous
prenez la parole très souvent je n'ai
pas l'habitude de vous interrompre merci
d'en faire autant je disais donc parmi
l'un des premiers inconvénient c'est que
tous les présidents de conseil général
seront membres du conseil régional et
croyez moi ça ne sera pas facile à gérer
pour le président du conseil
régionales ce qui serait encore pire
c'est si l'un d'entre eux des
conseillers généraux soit en même temps
président du conseil régional jean
claude parent d'or monsieur le président
monsieur le président nous avons connu
ça dans la région au moment de
l'établissement public régional et les
présidents les présidents de conseil
général n'avait aucune obligation d'être
côte conseil régional de le p r il avait
le choix et dans notre région
tous les présidents de conseil général
était membre de l'upm et bien j'étais
conseiller régional à l'époque
croyez moi qu'il y avait un poids un
poids du conseil généré gionale du
président je n'ai pas hésité à citer
pendant qu'il était sur le groupe qui se
constituer au cours des présidents de
conseil général
croyez moi ça ne facilitait pas du tout
du tout la tâche des uns et des autres
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles pour
laquelle en 1986 il a été décidé de
créer deux collectivités territoriales
totalement séparées dans laquelle
aujourd'hui heureusement il n'y a pas ou
peu de présidents de conseil général qui
sont en même temps au conseil régional
c'est un désavantage alors que là il va
y avoir un méli mélo et une osmose entre
les deux types d'assemblée qui va être
nuisible au bon fonctionnement de nos
institutions
je vous remercie bien monsieur madame
office tout de suite mais monsieur ne
nous en aurait pu ajouter qu'à cette
époque là celui qui présidait
il préside est tout seul y régler un
bureau en 10 minutes et y en avait un
qui décide et pour tout le monde et
personne ne dise rien pas plus vous que
moi c'était pas à l'elysée ali bongo
fils oui mais si monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
moi je suis assez à s'étonner de
l'argumentaire qui nous est donné pour
la création de ces territoires
quand on revient aux textes qui étaient
l'exposé des motifs de ce projet de loi
je crois que c'est très très intéressant
puisque dans cet exposé des motifs
il est dit très clairement il est dit
très clairement que on a du mal à suivre
je crois mais dans l'exposé des motifs
il est dit très clairement que la loi
qui nous est proposé elle nous est
proposé avec un conseiller territorial
parce que il n'a pas été possible de
supprimer les conseils généraux s'est
dit aussi clairement que ce que je dis
dans l'exposé des motifs
donc aujourd'hui qu'est ce que l'on nous
propose on nous propose des territoires
qui seront des bassins de vie et des
circonscriptions territoriales qui donc
recouperont ces bassins de vie et donc
garderont les communes telles quelles
sont pour en faire un ensemble
qu'est-ce que ça préfigure moi je sais
pas mais quand on y regarde d'un petit
peu plus près on se dit que c'est
cohérent avec un autre aspect du texte
dans lequel vous nous proposez des
regroupements d'établissements publics
de coopération intercommunale où vous
nous proposez des communes nouvelles qui
pourraient constituer ces ces nouvelles
structures chargées de gérer et on
imagine que petit à petit ces
territoires nouveaux que l'on a dans cet
article 1 les futures communes nouvelles
le ou les métropoles mais petit à petit
elles nous permettent de diffuser sur le
territoire la capacité de supprimer
réellement le conseil général on aura
réorganiser complètement les territoires
et on n'aura plus à avoir à l'échelon
national que une région et des
établissements de coopération
intercommunale qui seront probablement
tellement bien encadrés qu'ils ne seront
plus en capacité d'avoir une gestion
démocratique avec des électeurs en
capacité de peser sur les choix qui
devront être mis en oeuvre dans ces
territoires c'est ça sur le fond ce que
vous nous proposez et que vous ne voulez
pas affirmer pour ça que je crois que la
cohérence aurait voulu que la commission
accepte notre suppression complète du
chapitre premier dont je n'ai toujours
pas compris d'ailleurs pourquoi ce choc
notre amendement de suppression du
chapitre premier était irrecevable mais
bon peut-être qu'il y aura des
explications qui nous seront données à
un moment ou un autre jld et non à vous
avez parlé de la suppression vous avez
parlé du fait que le que le conseiller
territorial avait été créé moi je parle
de l'ensemble du chapitre premier je
parle pas obligatoirement de l'article
qui le crée donc je pense aujourd'hui
que ce qu'il faut et bien c'est qu'on
vote massivement l'abonnement de
suppression que nous avons proposées et
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous avez
demandé un scrutin public
dans ce cas là le scrutin public va être
organisé et je vous rappelle que la
commission est défavorable l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable on va
mettre aux voix les trois amendements
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
m'étrangler le teint blanc ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre en bus le train
bleu
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir un
bulletin rouge
allez
allez mes chers collègues le scrutin est
ouvert
bon ça ne demande à monter alors le
scrutin est clos et j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement des scrutins
selon
non
l'examen de la réforme des collectivités
territoriales touche à sa fin le vote
devrait avoir lieu cette nuit et l'ump
qui n'a pas la majorité absolue devra
compter sur les voix des centristes des
centristes qui ont rejeté l'une des
mesures phares de ce texte le mode de
scrutin du conseiller territorial tout
de suite retrouvé votre journal de 18
heures présenté par michel grossiord est
très bonne soirée